on parle de crise de régime de crise
sociale politique qui risque de
s'aggraver est-ce que vous admettez tout
ça est-ce que vous redoutez une
paralysie dès à présent du quinquennat
de la suite du conquête nous sommes dans
une situation qui n'est pas évidente je
le conçois en même temps ce sont les
outils démocratiques les outils qui
existent le 49-3 a toujours existé nous
l'utilisons parce que c'est important
c'est essentiel que cette réforme puisse
se mettre en oeuvre je rappelle que ça
veut dire que des cette année on va
pouvoir commencer à revaloriser les
petites pensions dès cette année je
pense qu'il y a beaucoup de gens
beaucoup de retraités qui attendaient ça
aussi c'est aussi ça que que qui se
jouait c'est pas uniquement des lois en
chambre c'est concrètement comment on
change la vie d'opensionner et grâce à
cette loi grâce au
travail qu'on a pu faire en CMP on va je
pense y revenir on a pu trouver une
commission mixparitaire
on a pu travailler toute une journée
très concrètement comment faire pour
améliorer le texte parce que le texte
qui a présenté Elizabeth borne au mois
de janvier et le texte qui a été qui est
à l'heure actuelle passée en 49-3 c'est
pas tout à fait le même on a beaucoup
beaucoup amélioré le texte donc pour
vous le 49-3 est un outil démocratique
il est constitutionnel certes mais dans
ce contexte selon vous les démocrates
oui oui c'est un outil démocratique
comme vous savez moi je je prends un peu
de recul nous avons été élu les députés
les sénateurs sont élus démocratiquement
il représente ils ont le l'autorité pour
faire des choix les choix politiques et
il les assume devant leurs électeurs la
rue elle a une légitimité c'est elle a
pas la légitimité je vais aller jusqu'au
bout elle a la légitimité et de n'a pas
la légitimité qu'on les représentants la
nation donc je pense qu'il faut pas tout
mettre dans dans un instant d'amalgame
oui il y a une difficulté je voulais je
voulais dit je l'ai dit de façon de très
claire ment mais l'essentiel pour nous
pour le pays c'est de passer cette
réforme c'est important et donc nous
utilisons les outils démocratiques qui
existent il y a pas de coup de force il
y a juste un utilisation des outils
démocratiques
[Musique]